DOEBOWE
PEOPL SAY HEOURETRE 2024
GOP?
E EAARIZONA AT
HE WAS THE STNESS ON
TUESDAAT JANUA
ING.
HE TOLD IN
HOW HE WAS AND
CAJOLE MINISTRATION, BY T
PRESIDENT, BY THE PR
LAWYERGIIA
WS WHO D TH
WHE GIUTO THE OUTCOME INGIUI S.
BAER 4th20TER THELTIRE, BOWERS
TOOKSU NOT  OG STATEMENT CRITICU
EFFORTS.
HE SAID, AS COERLIKEHELTOFL .PR
RE-ELECT HIM, BUT
I CANNOT AND WILL NON
A SUGGESON
CURRENT LAW HATHE  CERTIFI E
AND THEN RUSD
HIMSELAN S
TOIDICULE, SCORN AND THR EOPLE
BECAUSE  WDONAT"
REPORTED, QUOTE, BOWERS RECEIVED
MORE THAN 2000
10,000CE EVERYDAY.
ARD PROTESTERS GATHERED
OUTSD SCAM
THATA PEDOILWA
ZELENSKYY, LIZHENEY, JOCELYN
BENSON, SHAYE MO.
COMMITTEE.ONEL T AGAIN IN A ATEM
T BOWERS HADITED TRUMP WITH TH
OLD WA
GGHALD AGAINE OND IN FRONTF EN.
MEINOUNTER TO MY OATH WHEN I ORF
ANAND I OFY FOREIGN AS
ATEYIDOOTATION WITH QUALIFIED
ATTORNEYS.R
NAT YOU'RE ASKING ME T
I WILL NOT BREAKY
>> MANY WATCHED AND , HE GUY.
DOINT ING.O DESCHETE  AERS.
ANS, HAD TOLD E ASSOCIATED
ONALD TRUMP, NOMINIF HE WAS  BI
FIRST TIME BE COVID WA
.OOD FHE IN MY
PRETTY STUNNING UFF. GRAHAM OTIS
HEADLINE "THE COMMENT THAT
REPUBL PAR'SORAL
COLLAPSE" IFWE
W TRUMP AGAIN K FOR
JOINING ME NOWS RUSTY  THANKS S
HEREHELP US UNDERSTANDOU,  DINGT
WH FRINTIO
WAUSED MINO WHAT DO WHEN
K Y OTAIEN?YOU, WHO ARE YOU INI
IFTING THE CHOTHOSE JUTA
PO.'RE ASKING ME
YOU'VEENTIONED I AAT PI
OUT THAT W I
ARR BODY WSPCONSTIDATE PEOPLE A
M
ATTI
TIME IR STORY.
>> OKAY.
SO HER
HEOT I WD FETO GO WITHRUH DEN,
IN, THN  A
RE NOT GOING
AND KELICYDE
COE   LIIN IT ES
CONSERVINGY AND THTITUTIONS THA
T IN IN THE
PAST, BUT THATE CALE O
BELIGION.
AR
SELDS  THEHOICE IS
F ALTHEIR FAULTSHEOSBE THET I D.
IF YOU'RRA
L CHARR.U O DOCR THINK THAT'S T
CIATED PSSEDOF th COM
YOU VOTE FOR TULD VOTE FOR BIDBI
CAN I HAVE SOMEBOD, EASE?
BUCAE E
AND I'VE BEEN ON THE END OF -- R
ER THAA VORCE.
EN JUSLK COLD I' SOMEBODY SLACK.
BUT MI I'T WANT TO H
AND I DON'BODYTHROUGH THAT>> DIR
MAOUSSOCIATEESS STORY RA
E YOU' DEAD D TRUMP UNTIL YOU'RE
DON'T WANT TO BTELL
AN H.T  I
MAYBE TES BEFORE WE WENT
ONNTER
AB.
I'L YOU N,
OF TRUTHNDWITH IT G LIE,
NOITLIE.AND TH SAID.OL
SO IF REF I UY, .
I DON'T WANT H.
I DON' HIM.
>> BUTUE MISSING PIECE, MRT BEEE
DD
BELIEVES THEY WERE BEI ASKED
G ILGA
BERLDEVER VOTE FOR DONALD TRU .
IT'S NOT -THT  DONALA PLEA FOR E
LET'S WAKE UP.ST
CT
TLQUS OUR ENS,ARE , WHICH YOU JT
OM
I WA THAT PARTIC
EVEN THOUGH HEONE FREEDOMS
BE DIDN'HA
ODY WHHE
COUNTRY FROMEA THE ATHER THAN FE
AND I THIN--
ATTN MYART.
WHAT I HAVEN H IS,
TO SA WI ALTROU WANT AY THAT O
DO I WANT TO?THE ANSWERYES.
THAT'S WHA
OH  IGORCHALLENGES OF EILIVETHE
WALKSONTRAR
THEM.
MT VE THE CHARACTERO LEADCOUNTC
THESE KINDF POONS AREN